- [Narrator] The rocky inner
planets of our solar system
are thought to have mostly metallic cores,
a building block of planet formation.
But because the cores are
so difficult to reach,
scientists can only speculate
on their exact composition,
and what stories they might tell us
about the origins of our planets,
But that's about to change.
(rocket taking off)
- [NASA Employee] Vehicles
pitching down range.
- This is the first time
NASA has ever sent a mission
to this type of world,
a mostly metal world.
- [Narrator] Here's a
look at a NASA mission
to the asteroid, Psyche.
What scientists think is a metallic core
from a planet that never formed
and how the mission could tell us more
about the origins of planet Earth.
More than 1 million asteroids
have been discovered
in our solar system.
Of those millions, Psyche was
the 16th to be discovered,
dating back to the mid-1800s.
Most asteroids are made of rock and ice,
but scientists believe
the Psyche asteroid,
named after the greek goddess
of the soul, is made of metal.
- In the earliest days
of our solar system,
about 4.5 billion years ago,
there were a lot of objects made of metal
and rock and ice that were
violently colliding together,
some of them accreted to form the cores
and outer layers of our
planets like Earth and Mars.
The best theory so far is that Psyche
is one of the sort of exposed
cores of these planetesimals,
these planets that never came to be.
- [Narrator] But until
the Psyche spacecraft
arrives at the asteroid in 2029,
scientists can't say for certain
that this is Psyche's origin story.
- [Aylin] Even though we don't
know its origin and genesis
with complete certainty,
the value of a mission
like this is unprecedented.
- [Narrator] A recent analysis by NASA
indicates that Psyche is likely made
of a mixture of rock and metal,
with metal composing between
30-60% of its volume.
But why are scientists spending
more than $1 billion to study metal?
- The fact that it's
possibly the exposed core
of one of these
protoplanets is significant,
because Earth formed from the accretion
of many, many protoplanets.
And so Psyche is one small microcosm
of a building block of what
came to make Earth, Earth.
- [Narrator] Earth's outer core
lies at a depth of over 1,800 miles.
So far, scientists have only drilled down
about seven and a half of those miles,
because that's as far as our
current technology can take us.
- And because we can't travel back in time
to the earliest days of our solar system
and we can't right now delve into
the center of our own planet,
Psyche provides this excellent proxy
for trying to better
understand the evolution
of our planetary neighborhood.
- [Narrator] To study the
asteroids composition,
the Psyche spacecraft,
made by Maxar Technologies
and NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory,
will carry a payload of
scientific instruments.
The instruments will determine
if Psyche has a magnetic field,
study its chemical and
mineral composition,
and map out its topography.
Psyche is currently the only
known place in our solar system
where scientists can examine
directly what may contain metal
from the core of a planetesimal.
- NASA seems to be,
in what some scientists call
the golden age of asteroids.
Asteroids and small bodies like comets
were ignored for a long time
in lieu of going to the moon
and trying to figure
out how to get to Mars.
And now I think NASA is really
putting its money where its mouth is
in terms of exploring
these types of worlds.
And while the most recent
asteroid related mission
brought back samples
from a different asteroid
and Psyche isn't bringing back samples,
the rarity of this metallic world
and what we could learn from it
really is what gives this mission value.
(upbeat music)